[Applause]
so I was watching Batman vs Superman for
some reason which I guess isn't
entertaining enough film albeit not
cinematic masterpiece by any stretch but
as I was watching it I noticed something
very strange that took me so much by
surprise that I had to discuss it with
my friends afterwards after we had
watched it now it takes place right at
the end of the film so obviously if you
haven't seen the film I'm gonna go into
heavy spoiler territory here it's right
at the climax of the film when Superman
Batman and Wonder Woman have teamed up
to fight this monster there's a lot of
action a lot of special effects a lot of
just a lot and then it evolves into a
point where Superman feels like he has
to sacrifice himself in order to save
the others and the rest of the city and
mankind basically which he then does the
bad guy die of Superman is dying it's
all very sad bla bla bla but then we get
to this scene do you see you too isn't
that a cross it's kind of prominent in
the shot too seriously think about it
Superman has just sacrificed his own
life to save mankind and right at that
moment there is a cross slapped on the
screen is Superman Jesus is that the
symbolism that's going on here now I
don't know if I completely overanalyzing
this was this on purpose was it a
complete coincidence or some mysterious
option in between these two
I mean Christian symbolism in movies and
popular culture isn't unusual we all
know that Narnia is about Jesus for
example I'm not sure about Zack Snyder's
religious conviction I don't really feel
like looking it up right now but could
it be that they consciously made a very
clear Jesus reference in this superhero
movie it's interesting to think about
how our religious traditions have
affected our societies to such a large
extent even if the cross is coincidental
the story is very reminiscent of the
story of Jesus in the Bible it is after
all one of the most famous stories of
all time and one that is so ingrained
into our sort of cultural consciousness
that we don't even really think about it
when it comes to many Western countries
we like to look at ourselves as very
secularized here in Sweden where I live
we're often viewed as the most secular
country in the world and there may be
some truth to this from a certain
perspective but at the same time
Christianity has been the dominant
religion here for so long and che
so much of our traditions that its
presence is inescapable regardless if we
want to or not our society is completely
infused with Christianity its present in
our moral values how we treat each other
the elderly the poor it's not beliefs
whether we're or not we sort of realize
it when many Westerners are asked what
religion is that answer that it's about
belief in something a very Lutheran
Christian idea we celebrate holidays
they're a Christian we have symbols in
our windows during Christmas times that
are Christians but usually at that point
we say oh but they aren't religious and
maybe they don't carry the religious
meanings that they once did but they are
still a religious tradition that we rely
on and lean back on in times of crisis
we often fall back on our cultures
religious beliefs when many Swedes
passed away in the tsunami in 2004
priests were standing by the airport to
bless the bodies as they arrived when a
loved one passes we want a funeral and a
priest to save some words about it to
sort of reassure us this is common all
over the world
even those who sort of don't consider
themselves religious often fall back on
the religious traditions of our peers or
our family in times of crisis it's also
present in the way we tell stories and
thus how we conceive and understand the
world around us certain stories like the
passion story of Christ have left such a
mark on our cultural consciousness it is
programmed into our very views on the
world it is almost like second nature
Carl Jung very famously talked about the
archetypes of mythologies that all myths
follow different archetypes that are
sort of buried in the subconscious of
humanity
and while these theories are mostly
discarded by scholars of religion today
it does say something about our
relationship to stories stories shape us
and then we shape stories in turn as a
result it's this what has happened in
Batman vs Superman has this ingrained
story of Christ crept its way into the
film subconsciously through some kind of
cultural programming what then of the
cross is that also a kind of
subconscious accident probably not maybe
it's simply a coincidence that that
image appeared at that specific moment
and in that shot maybe it was indeed all
on purpose
none of the alternatives seemed all too
far-fetched to me or perhaps I'm simply
over analyzing everything like always
and there's nothing really interesting
thing going on here perhaps this is just
about a superhero alien from Krypton who
sacrifices himself for his two friends a
man who dresses up in a bad suit to
fight crime and gal gadot in any case it
did make for an interesting moment in an
otherwise let's face it dull film I'll
see you next time
[Music]